[Musique]
regardez ce que je vois là bas hélas
après six heures de marche
la lumière au bout du tunnel on voit
enfin la maison du père noël où est trop
comment cette petite mignonne riz au
milieu de la forêt éclairé c'est magique
c'est juste magique
[Musique]
les amis regardez ce que vous voyez là
c'est la maison de celui pour qui on a
fait des kilomètres et des kilomètres il
est là vous voyez son règne hélas son
traîneau également et le père noël a
fait son maximum pour exaucer vos goûts
le père noël
n'a pas pu exaucer tous les jeunes le
père noël
est un homme formidable ça n'est pas un
magicien il y en a parmi vous qui vont
être heureux il y en a un ou une qui va
connaître
un moment d'émotion exceptionnel et
quand je vis exceptionnel c'est dans le
sens magic du terme je vous demander
d'être les plus respectueux possible
vous allez le voir dans le respect total
oui il ya des toilettes j'ai envie d'y
aller faire quelques schipper noël avec
tout le respect que je lui dois bien sûr
bah oui c'est elle c'est la bouffe à
lambèse s'il vous plaît je vais vous
donner le plus grand respect avant qu'on
y aille je vais retourner je vous poser
de questions est-ce que ça va oui oui
est-ce qu'on voit marais on peut y aller
[Rires]
[Musique]
bonjour père de rennes où joue bonjour
mais si grill bonjour aussi la cie merci
ça va bien d'une phase de ronnie est
très bien merci père noël cameron je
suis venu avec mes amis je m'asseyais
sont les chroniqueurs toujours installé
un staline on commence par une question
importante est ce que vous savez en
france
père noël merci de nous recevoir
père noël comme tu peux le voir je pense
tutoie le père noël -
je tutoie j'ai tant appris merci père
noël comme tu peux le voir père noël
sont de grands enfants
ils ont fait chacun un voeu est envoyé
tous une lettre avant de te rencontrer
mathieu delormeau tu avais demandé de
retrouver son anonymat et je crois que
très vite on a vu que tu ailles exaucé
son voeu
jean michel mr oui ton veut est ce que
tu peux reformule et on le paie
entretien est électrique ou non on a pu
voir père noël on a mis tout en oeuvre
pour essayer d'exaucer le deuxième feu
parce que les trottinettes électriques
c'est moins notre truc
on
mais
[Musique]
alice russell
ouais bingo maintenant je préfère qu'on
reste amis je me frottais leblanc
malheureusement ton veut n'a pas été
exaucé
delphine tu n'es pas formulé deux mais
je crois que tu as passé un très beau
séjour et je pense qu'aujourd'hui ton
veut si ça avait été d'avoir une
nouvelle famille eh bien je crois que
l'on veut être exaucé il en a fait une
couple
est ce que tu es heureux celle ci est à
pontida man ray sera peut être ton ton
souhait au carbone oui vraiment rentrer
un voyage au soleil avec roger s roger
oui oui serré au père noël itunes et de
rien je vous simple maxime ton veut
c'était de trouver l'amour dans contre
la mère noël mamère noël malheureusement
tu rencontres juste le permettre c'est
déjà énorme puisque tourbeux est déjà
magnifique d'ailleurs il ya un point
commun entre père noël vous et qui
j'écris à chaque fois que j'écris une
lettre où ne répondait jamais
aujourd'hui même merci père noël vous
êtes vraiment très sympa de 2 rien merci
perdrait il son milieu le voeu kelly
de vous marier oui en 2019
j'espère que vos deux voeux vont se
rencontrer pour ne faire plus qu'un
[Musique]
je vous espère
battre en tête à vis tu es formule 1
veut rester quoi c'était de retrouver un
corps de rêve tu as mis tout en oeuvre
youssef aussi
[Musique]
moi j'avais 7
aujourd'hui père noël tu va exaucer le
dommage à bah c'est pas merci encore un
peu de chemin à faire que les progrès
énormes
isabelle tu avait formulé un voeu qui
est telle qu'elle rencontrait un renne
de rencontres à rennes alors ici ton
veut été plus qu'exaucé dix minutes il
est plus exaltante de ma vie tu as vécu
ton rêve et c'est vrai que je rappelle
que tu es travailler dans un zoo si tu
adores les animaux puisque
et que tu vois un animal tu te frotte à
[Musique]
[Rires]
sa belle
ton voeu a été exaucé tu peux remercier
père noël vraiment plus caroline on veut
était
[Musique]
thomas
dans ma copine est tombé n'a pas été
exaucé puisque ça dormi avec un faux
père noël est malheureusement le père
noël ne peut pas accueillir chimiques
espagnol la merde alors non mais c'est
vrai que là-bas noël serait jalouse
forcément bien entendu pour vena pas été
exaucé mais tu rencontres le père noël
est père noël je vous le redis c'est un
grand honneur pour moi de me trouver à
vos côtés